welcome to the afternoon station our
speaker will be Christopher Thomas
thanks time
okay so today I'm gonna be talking about
a problem that isn't something we
traditionally studied in randomized
linear algebra but that we've been able
to solve using hope maybe a lot this is
one clicker that we've been able to
solve using tools from randomizing your
ocular in particular I'll be talking
about a very classic problem in signal
processing maybe the most classic
problem is to go processing in how we
can use randomized how Grimek tools to
better understand this problem and get
better dia reticle balanced and better
practical rhythms that previously
existed so this is the problem we are
going to be talking about just fitting
continuous functions based on the
discrete number of samples from the
continuous function so I have some
function y defines between you can think
of it as over over time I'll say time a
lot but doesn't have any time it could
be time it could be space it could be
anything it's so fine between 0 to Big T
and we want to take a number of discrete
samples of that function and using those
samples interpolate the continuous
function ok those samples might be noisy
so it might be that we can't access Y
but inside Y where we have some
perturbation of our samples ok so and of
course our goal is to recover some
function y tilde it's a little hard to
see the grey function of these but some
function of Y tilde that's close to the
true function Y over the entire interval
0 to T I wanted over that whole fixed
interval ok and we want to know how many
samples do you require to reconstruct
this function to do interpolation and
once we get those samples how do we
reconstruct the function in an efficient
way
ok so naively this is an ill-posed
problem if I don't make any assumption
about my signal there's no reason to
believe that discrete samples on a
continuous signal will give any
information
about the whole signal right I could
have some crazy signal jumping all
around so it's an ill-posed problem
unless I make some sort of assumption
about the signal like a smoothness
assumption and by far one of the most
common ways to add structure to your
signal in signal processing is to make
an assumption about its Fourier
transform so we don't impose structure
on the signal itself but we look at the
continuous Fourier transform which I
have up there Y hat XE which is my
notation for e for frequencies and we
say we believe this Fourier transform is
structured in some way
the most common way the most common type
of structure we see is we say the
Fourier transform of the signal is band
limited so in particular their signal is
composed only of frequencies within a
certain band limit F so it doesn't
contain any higher frequencies than app
and then you can ask how you can solve
this interpolation problem when your
single band limited in this of course is
a very well studied problem going back
to the work of Shannon way to Kerr
Nyquist and others it's really at the
foundation of signal processing and
information theory how do you sample
your signal how do you sample
band-limited signals and reconstruct
them ah so everyone else to think back
to like their undergrad signal
processing course and I hope everyone
remembers this if I have a function of
band limit T I can sample it uniformly
at the Nyquist frequency
I'm sorry band limit F so the example a
uniformly of the Nyquist frequency which
means I need to take 1 over 2 F samples
per second okay that's what I need to
reconstruct the function actually
there's a very simple algorithm for
reconstructing the function once you
take those uniform samples which is sinc
interpolation or some is called Shannon
Whittaker interpolation what you do is
at any point T that's not one of our
samples we're just going to set its
value Y tilde of T equal to the sum of
I'm gonna place a sinc function with
with F at each of my other the samples I
took and I'm gonna look at like a point
T and sum up the value at of all of
those sinc functions
so that's how you can recover a signal
from its Nyquist rate samples okay so
that's like great theory
unfortunately sinc interpolation doesn't
work over finite intervals from zero to
T in theory or in practice so in
particular it's that theory that you can
recover the function really depends on
the fact that we're talking about
samples that's what spacing 1 over 2 f
going all the way out to infinity and it
really is important that if I want to
reconstruct the signal at a point y of T
I need to take the syncs going out from
0 to infinity because if I instead have
a function of our bounded interval and I
truncate this sum of syncs I get a lot
of error because the sinc function
doesn't fall off quickly it falls off
like 1 over X so if I try to analyze
Shannon Whittaker interpolation for that
first problem I stated you get something
that has polynomial dependence on some
accuracy parameter epsilon which is
something we would like to avoid okay so
this sort of a well-known problem that
these classical sampling results don't
extend to when you actually care about
doing things in practice over finite
intervals but fortunately there's a
really beautiful line of work that deals
with exactly this problem and in
particular if I want to reconstruct
vandeman signals okay there's this line
of work by sleppy and Landau in public
on what are known as prolate spheroidal
wave functions this work from the 60s
combined with more recent work by
vladimir rockling and his co-authors
says that i can remove that polynomial
epsilon dependence I'm going to say I
get some signal Y that's equal it's
Fortran it's the Fourier transform of
some function X plus y noise and they
say that I can reconstruct Y up to error
that depends on the two norm of my for
signal plus some factor depending on my
noise using just ft plus wide 1 over
samples okay
ot is my time bounce so I'm going from
zero to T so classical sampling Theory
you're taking one over half samples per
second so if Shannon Whittaker
interpolation worked over fix in a row
you'd get ft samples but to make it
actually go through and ft over epsilon
and we're gonna this this work gets ft
plus log 1 over epsilon okay so we have
an epsilon parameter depending on the
energy of X the two norm of X because
them if you have a band limit signal it
can also jump around crazy if you're
willing to pour enough energy into your
Fourier transform so that's why that
term appears and then this term see
think of as a constant because I'm not
going to be able to recover my signal to
anything better than additive error
depending on the size of my noise so
ideally C would be one but if we can get
it up to two we'd also be happy with
that so X is in Fourier domain so we're
only gonna cover we're recovering X that
is band truly band limited and then
we're evaluating this error when I say
sub T there that means we're evaluating
the error only between 0 and T yeah so
you only match the interval yeah so we
measure the area the air the air as
between wide tilde and this noisy thing
called why why is the true signal so oh
oh yeah maybe I sorry this is this is
not how I should have said it it should
be that Y is equal to F star of X and
then we observe F star of X plus n yeah
usually were actually gonna think about
the noiseless case so I think in the
future signs that won't matter but yeah
I could pick up okay so that's the
theorem the way it's proven is basically
sleppy on land on public show there are
these really nice smooth functions
called prolate spheroidal wave functions
that can serve as a smooth basis for all
band-limited functions on 0 to T and
then just like polynomials or other
smooth functions you can construct a
quadrature scheme for actually like
projecting a signal onto that basis so
that's sort of very roughly how you get
a result like this ok yeah yeah so if
it's functions on a circle you and you
assume your functions periodic then you
can reduce everything to discrete for
your case so then these sort of issues
don't show up you can take yeah so
there's truly four continuous functions
around making noise and I'm assuming I
can't move to discrete Fourier okay so a
very important conclusion from this line
of work and which comes out of the fact
that you're using quadrature rules to
project onto these purlettes periodical
wave functions is that you actually
shouldn't be using uniform sampling so
the quadrature rules that you can prove
work do non-uniform sampling on the
interval where they concentrates time
samples near the ends of your interval
and this saves you essentially in theory
a quadratic potentially quadratic loss
that you would get from uniform sampling
or you could have suffered a one over
polynomial epsilon loss and this
shouldn't be surprising I mean if you've
seen an interpolation of polynomials in
general if we want good approximation of
functions we need to concentrate more
samples towards the end is very interval
okay so what about for your structure
beyond land band-limited functions in
today's world we often care about
signals that aren't necessarily
band-limited I'm sure everyone's heard
of compressed sensing sparse recovery
often our assumption is something very
different for example that our signal is
composed of a small number of
frequencies that might be over a very
wide band
alternatively it's very common to assume
that your signal is a multiband signal
so it's composed of frequencies in some
union of bands and then even more
generally when you take a Bayesian
perspective of this problem you say I'm
not just going to restrict my signal to
have frequencies within some limited
subset but you place different weights
on frequencies and you say I'm putting a
prior on what I believe my signal is and
I think higher frequencies are gonna be
less likely than smaller frequencies and
I want to solve like a statistical neste
nation problem under that prior so
Gaussian priors are very common cashy
lorentz priors are very common if you've
heard of kriging kernel regression
Gaussian process regression all of these
are equivalent to solving a Bayesian or
regression problem where you place some
smooth prior on the frequencies in your
Fourier transform okay they have
countless applications in the sciences
and Geoscience is really anywhere we are
analyzing time or space and trying to
fit a Smith function so what do we know
about these much more general classes of
signals really not much if we're looking
at the finite interval 0 to T 50 years
after there's really nice work on
prolate spheroidal wave functions we
don't know anything in terms of tight
theoretical bounds for recovering
signals how many samples do we need how
do we do it efficiently this changed
slightly a couple years ago so there's
this really nice sequence of papers by
chen kane price and song i think eric
price is around here I'm not sure if
he's here buddy is somewhere out ok yeah
where basically they solve this
continuous function fitting problem for
sparse signals ok so our work really
builds on this work except we're trying
to solve it for a much much broader
class of constraints on your Fourier
transform
so actually before I stayed our results
are there any questions about the basic
problem setup yeah no you know um
something is optimum or that's known for
sparse for your functions now and for
band-limited for your functions it's
sort of known practically for many more
classes of functions but we don't have
that the arms to back it up okay so what
our result is is three ingredients the
first which I'm going to talk the least
about today is we give a very general
way of characterizing this the sample
complexity for function fitting problems
when you have some set of constraints or
priors on your Fourier transform and
what we give is essentially a tight
characterization so an easy to compute
function that matches up with what you
what we expect for classes we know like
band limit it takes about ft samples
bars takes about case samples and also
we can prove that our characterization
is tight it's the minimum number of
samples you need to recover continuous
signals in all of these classes the
second part is the algorithmic part how
do you take these samples and what we
show is that there's actually a uniform
a universal non uniform sampling scheme
that works for any creep prior on your
Fourier transform frequencies so in
particular we saw a non uniform sampling
scheme for band-limited functions you
can use a very very similar non uniform
sampling scheme and it works for solving
any of these constrained for normal
function fitting problems so ya know my
really no matter what your signals are
so today I'm going okay today I'm not
I'm gonna try not to talk too much about
the Bayesian stuff because there's just
a lot of notation when I say solves it
for the smooth priors will get like in
very tight approximation of the map as
the map estimator in a Bayesian setting
for constraints will get sort of a
natural recovery guarantee like what I
said they get from those
okay and then finally we have the
samples we give an efficient algorithm
that can compute this function y tilde
of T for most essentially any prior that
comes up in practice there's like one
thing you need from that prior that I'll
explain later so that's the results and
what why I'm talking about here is it
really all uses tools from randomized
numerical linear algebra applied in art
ascending to continuous operators so I'm
suggesting maybe we should call it
randomized numerical functional analysis
but for you guys I'm gonna do everything
in the picture of length of matrices and
really all the tools we know for
matrices carry over to these continuous
function fitting problems okay so this
is work that will be on archive soon to
my co-authors hi and the camera around
today so okay so let's just formulate
the problem formally for when we're
looking at looking at more general
priors on our Fourier transform we're
going to do that and this will get to
your question about Bayesian inference
by defining a weighted Fourier transform
which I'm going to call f mu star it's
over weighted inverse Fourier transform
I'm calling it f you start you is is
what I'm going to call the distribution
that constrains my Fourier transform
okay use that distribution so for
band-limited functions it's like a
uniform distribution over an interval
but it can be any positive distribution
okay so the waited for a transform is I
look at my standard for inverse Fourier
transform Atrix and I just add weights
to different frequencies corresponding
to new and I say I want to solve that
exact I also have the notation messed up
in the side but I want to solve that
exact recovery problem that I said for
band-limited functions I'm going to
assume that Y that I can observe F mu
star of X for some function X plus noise
and I want to recover a signal Y tilde
that's close to my true signal in closed
means that I have some epsilon
dependence on the immune or of X plus a
constant
times the norm of my noise so just so I
have it done formally when I say the two
one that's like the two norm over zero
to T and I say them you norm
that's also that's the two norm but it's
under the waiting mu of the frequency
okay so an epsilon the two normal
parameter because if I have more energy
my signal and I take more samples I can
get a better fit but C is not because I
can't hope to do better than a comma
then one times my nose so I just care
about getting like one or two something
like that okay so when you think about
constrained Fourier transforms sparse
pan limited multi bands
this Maps exactly on to the function
recovery prom we're talking about you're
going to recover a signal close to true
signal with no error depending on the to
Murom of that signal over the flat
frequencies it gets a little bit more
confusing to think about what this
recovery guarantee looks like for smooth
priors but one way to think about it is
you if a function it uses is less likely
so it uses like frequencies that have a
low weight it's not hard to check that a
solution of this has a higher weight X
so you'll get like more error if it's
some rarer function and you can make
those formal through a Bayesian
framework which we do in the paper but
I'm not gonna talk about today okay so
how do we solve this function fitting
problem we reduce it to a regression
problem and this is a very very popular
idea it's the idea behind Gaussian
process regression it's been used all
over the place in the field we're gonna
say that and this just takes like five
minutes of working through on a piece of
paper if I find some function G that
approximate G tilde that approximately
solves this regression problem the
Fourier transform of that function the
weighted for your transform will be a
will be close to you why so it will be a
good Y tilde what's this regression
problem it's saying I want G to both
when I multiply it by its Indian we
waited in verse for a transform it
should be close to Y my true signal and
there's a penalty depending on the to
the two norm of G under my
function so where's the noise did you
treat the noise than this so yeah I sort
of think of this as a noiseless for now
he's the easiest way to think about it
I think I'm yeah but actually let's
let's think of why is not having noise
so just because I slightly missed to
find my Y early on but we can think of
the noiseless case all these problems
are still unknown in the noiseless case
so when you have noise this would have
moist and what I would be claiming is
that we get some Y tilde that's close to
the noiseless Y so I mean this is not
this is of course not a problem I can
solve because it's this is a continuous
operator like it's a regression problem
defined from 0 to T I would need all
sample sum 0 to t two sovereign gresham
problem like this you can solve it by
discritization meaning that we just sub
sample some rows of that regression
problem this exactly corresponds to sub
sampling time domain points in my
function and I can at least discretize
yeah so I basically described as one
dimensions regression problem just by
sampling times ok there's actually
another infinite dimension in my
regression problem which is the
frequency domain we don't actually need
to worry about that so I claim that we
can avoid discretized in the frequency
domain completely as long as we have
some closed form solution some clothes
from formula for the Fourier transform
of my weight matrix my weight
distribution you the reason is is
because you can reduce this problem
where have only sub sample time points
basically to a kernel Ridge regression
problem where the kernel is the Fourier
transform of meal I'm not going to go
through the details of this this is
what's done in Gaussian process
regression really anytime people solve
these problems all they care about is
getting a time domain the time domain
samples and then as long as you have a
explicit formula for hat new hat you can
solve this regression problem using
kernel Ridge regression techniques
so really oh yeah and I just wanted to
mention that for most of the constraints
we see the mean they're very explicit
functions so we we know closed form
solutions for the Fourier transform so
really our job reduces to this problem
of figuring out a sample time domain
points and the way we're going to do
that is just use the exact same tools
we've been using for sampling discrete
regression problems which you've heard
about quite a bit this morning we can
solve this regression problem
approximately if we sample rows meaning
time points by their statistical average
score in in particular their ridge
leverage score which I have defined here
okay I'm not going to talk about the
definition of this just yet but we'll
get to that so you can sample by these
probabilities which are equal the
statistical average were the some of
those statistical average scores is
equal to something called the
statistical and mention a regression
problem
SMU of Epsilon now we need to take SMU
of epsilon samples approximately to get
a good approximate solution for the
regression problem so s-view of lambda
when you check it for functions we know
about like band-limited function sparse
functions it matches up with exactly the
best known number of samples you need to
solve the function fitting problem so we
sort of know it's a good is a good
measure for sample complexity and
actually you can prove it's an optimal
measure for any of these constraint for
your fitting problems you can roughly
think of SMU of epsilon as equaling the
number of eigenvalues larger than
epsilon it's sort of like a natural
scimitar ization of our weighted Fourier
transform it's of this matrix that's
this this does not look like this is
basically like a positive semi definite
operator
yes exactly it only depends on you so
the number for amou you can define this
operator and this is not exactly a
number of eigenvalues greater than
epsilon but you can think of it as
roughly as that because if lambda is
greater than epsilon this is like 1
between 1/2 and 1 and then it have
something that depends sort of on the
tail of the eigenvalues but for
operators in this continuous setting the
tail falls off very fast so it basically
goes to 0 so think of it as a number of
eigenvalues greater than Epsilon what
revisit that in a bit ok so the trouble
is these leverage scores are hard to
compute even for discrete problems and
we actually have a more challenging
problem here because we can't just
compute them for some discrete values of
time we need to compute them for like a
continuum of time and then sample by the
leverage scores over that continuum
seems hard but fortunately have a lot of
structure on our side so let's look at
exactly what this leverage 4 equals
let's ignore this regularization term
for a second what it is is I'm looking
at a function f mu star of G and I'm
saying what's the maximum squared value
of that function at time point t over
the average squared value and I'm doing
this for a restricted class of function
so I'm saying take the maximum over
functions G that don't have too high of
norm under that weight view because if
she had really high norm this bottom
part of the fraction gets big
so leverage really goes off to 0 so I'm
saying under sort of like low norm
functions what's the maximum value of
the function at T over its average bird
value this is something that for many
types of functions we know how to bound
and like in functional analysis
approximation Theory we really care
about obtaining bounds like this so if
you're familiar with like polynomials
bounds on the leverage score are given
by the classic Bernstein equality or
Markov Brothers inequality so the bird
seen in equality set bounds exactly what
I just said you can use it to bound
exactly the squared value of a
polynomial at some points he over the
average squared value of that polynomial
by basically if the polynomial of degree
K K divided by the distance of the time
point from the edge of the interval
and Markov brothers use a similar bound
but it says that the edge of the
interval the polynomial can jump to at
most k squared times its average squared
value okay so when we have a bound like
that that means we can just explicitly
bound for polynomials the leverage
quarters by a function like this and if
we integrate out this function I wanted
to mention this is exactly why I like
you need to use some non-uniform
distribution when you're trying to fit
polynomials so people often talk about
chebyshev notes if you instead did a
randomized scheme for interpolating
polynomials using a distribution like
this saying I need to sample more at the
edge in the interval as less as I fall
off would give something that was very
similar to the chebyshev polynomial so
it's exactly this type of distribution
you need to avoid these like ringing
effects that happen when you're trying
to interpolate with uniform importance
so we can look at this this distribution
and we can say what's the total sum or
average scores you integrate out these
rectangles on the end and you get
something that's like K and you
integrate under this curve and you get
something like K log K so using leverage
per sampling we can fit polynomials with
K log K samples which is a lot factored
off with like the best known math that's
what you got from chebyshev polynomials
what about for your [ __ ] train for
your functions
you can show that you can do basically
the exact same sorts of downs for sparse
for your functions and that's sort of
one of the key results in this recent
line of work on fitting sports for your
functions essentially you can get the
same bounds on this leverage core
function explicit bounds except you have
a K to the fourth there instead of K
squared sort of the intuition for a
result like this is that sparse for your
functions if you have frequencies that
are close together they sort of behave
like low degree polynomials modulated by
some complex exponential and the
frequencies are far away from each other
they're sort of orthogonal to each other
so it's like the very rough idea why you
can't bounce like this you can get very
similar bounds to the polynomial bounds
for sparse for your functions and what
our key result is how do you extend
these balance to all mu all prior
distributions can we do that by using
even more tools from randomized linear
algebra so one of the big lessons of
randomized linear algebra I guess for
the past decade or more is that if I
want an optimal she rank approximation
to a matrix instead of just using this
is from all different lines of work that
will care about this week instead of
using Q singular vectors I can get a
pretty much optimal approximation that
reconstructs my matrix using Q actual
columns from the matrix in our language
this means that if mu had statistical
dimension SMU of epsilon I can pretty
much approximate that weighted inverse
Fourier transform by a factorization of
this form that looks like a sparse it
has only a small number of frequencies
times some recombination matrix this
means that gee if it's small and norm
under mu looks like something that's the
sum of a small number of complex
Exponential's so it's sparse plus noise
and what that allows you to do is
translate these bounds for sparse for
rare functions exactly over two bounds
for for functions that are constrained
under any distribution meal so I'm not
doing the going to go into any of the
details of that but the takeaway is we
can essentially say
time points by a distribution that looks
very very similar to what we did for
polynomials or sparse for your functions
and you got a really simple function out
the sample points by this fix
distribution you use the year form of
the inverse before a transform of new to
construct the kernel matrix and then you
solve a kernel Ridge regression problem
on this discrete kernel matrix to get a
function fit to y over the interval so
that's that's it that's the whole
algorithm yeah it's like a linear system
we're using our kernel matrix is your
final algorithm and then there's like a
simple summary constructs the value of y
till the T at any time point t so that
epsilon is that the same episode on they
can have a new arrow phone yes that's
the same epsilon we have under error
bound yeah so you might need to do like
a binary search over epsilon or
something because you don't necessarily
know that epsilon a priori so there's a
bunch of open questions but actually I
think I'm tight on time so I'll leave
them up and I suppose take questions
[Applause]
interpolate in polynomial functions
using leverage course that's you right
uh I suppose it hasn't been written down
but it's it's really it's pretty easy to
prove using these bounds and it may be
Eric you guys have been wrote this down
at some point yeah so it's quite
directed one nice thing about that is
you can use that result for polynomials
to read arrive fitting for band-limited
functions so you can match like all that
stuff it's okay if I could already look
at it in fact the comparative sit for
the Mobius right yeah the usual reason
no no it's not actually I used to
suspect that maybe because my analysis
not tight the reason yeah that's the
classical reason for leverage 14 oh yeah
oh no way it's not sorry I meant like
it's not off because the point it's not
because like some it's not that I got a
bound of K and then could have gotten it
by only gotten that log K from random
sampling at least for us we only bounded
the sum of leverage squares by K log K
so really if we did random sampling we
would lose two log factors but maybe
there's a way of making that tighter so
that yeah there is and I have this as an
open question there should be a hope of
deterministic variant also for like any
of these function classes I talked about
yeah well we don't have yeah getting a
deterministic interpreted like
interpolation scheme space of it that's
not known yet you avoid that using our
method but it's a random sampling scheme
so maybe you could avoid it maybe you
could use these ideas from leverage
worse to spit out like some fixed number
of samples like the chebyshev notes that
I just know ahead of time and can use
you can't use indoor soccer and there's
actually a bunt I forget the names
there's a bunch of solvers that people
already use for band-limited functions
that don't have that you can view as
iterative solvers of this problem oh
yeah
here's a matrix so you can use any other
symmetric yet symmetric is positive
definite
[Applause]